hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chances.com so i would like to make
another update guys on the high dollar
cryptocurrency because i made an update
last week i told you guys that we will
push higher we are right now pushing
higher so let's check everything again
uh what is this cryptocurrency why i do
believe in this project and what are the
price targets let's get into it
[Music]
all right so very quickly we start with
the technicals guys so this is the
information i get from pancake swap i'm
going to show you in this video very
quickly how to access pancake swap and
how to buy high dollars there we can see
that since i made the video which was
last week around 80 here we pushed
higher we almost doubled guys since last
week because
we can see that i don't have the whole
uh price action here but there was a
break out here and there was some news
coming you know once again i know some
people from this company so i get public
information that i get it slightly
earlier maybe so i uh got the
information here that they're gonna
start to be in touch with some gaming
companies and that
this is just going in the right
direction that the uh it's might be get
listed soon so to get listed they need
to get uh attention from the big
expansions like binance or kraken or
whatever and they need to show the
people's interest so that they get
listed if they do get listed it's gonna
do times 10 maybe or something like this
so this is not coming yet but the price
action we're seeing for the past uh two
weeks is you know just a good uh sign
for this news potential news that might
be coming so technicals are good i think
we might reach two quickly it looks to
me like we are in the third wave uh we
might like i said reach two by the end
of the month or the year something like
this
uh for now as long as we stay above the
streamline we are bullish guys and we
are consolidating for the past few days
i have a feeling that there's gonna be a
breakout on the upside and then it's
gonna keep pushing higher now if you
didn't buy high dollar yet i'm not sure
it's the risk reward is still that
interesting but you can just click on
the link in description of this video
let me explain what is the high dollar
it's a non-profit cryptocurrency so
organization that basically is based on
a referral system so if you subscribe to
this project just by clicking on the
link in description of this video you're
gonna be able to claim every day high
dollars and the more people you are
referring uh the more high dollars
you're gonna receive if they claim it as
well so this is how it's working and
they have reached by doing that 1.7
million members uh in a few months only
like three months so this is basically
what uh is giving me uh the good
impression about this project it's the
how fast it's growing and like i said i
know people from this project and
they're very serious people they have a
very big ambition
i know they are from this industry some
of them for a long time so i believe in
uh the people that are working there so
there is a big team of i don't know
maybe 50 100 people devoted to make it
grow and they're doing a very nice job
uh for now so i think it's gonna keep
happening and the news to me that was uh
quite good here they're gonna allow
users to use their token in some games
in restaurants in hotels so they
basically you know grow their ecosystem
quite nicely and this is the reason why
i do believe in this project
so right now if you want to get in like
i said the easiest way is just to
subscribe and to claim that every day
your tokens but you can also share if
you go on coin market cap okay you tap
high dollar okay so here we can see the
price here you can see that ninety four
percent of the volume is traded on the
pancake swap and not uni swap uni swap
the spread is too high
don't go there go on packing swap if you
want to buy some so to do that you just
go on hide.com here you have many
information you can read if you are
interested they explain the project you
you click on go to pancake swap i'm just
re-explaining quickly the process guys
if you want to get in because
you know 140 is still cheap for this
cryptocurrency all right and you just
arrive on this page you select usd and
high dollar here and it's the easiest
way to get some now there is another way
to get some high dollars is just by uh
going on the website and clicking
buy high dollars so
bam you go here buy high dollars you
then need to connect
so i'm not gonna do it right now guys i
don't want everyone to get my phone
number but you sign in and you can buy
high dollars uh the only issue is that
they this is not allowed unfortunately
for american people this is just the low
so they are not allowed to sell
cryptocurrency directly to american
people but if you do that you can stake
it for one year two years or four years
and get a discounted price discounted by
75 if you stick it for four years
so this is another way to buy discounted
high dollars but it's to be kept on the
long term so this is it for today i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget guys to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
sure see you guys